i'm such a fan of this guy and i've told
it to his face when i've had a fortune
to uh be uh in his presence one of the
greatest i think compliments you can
give an actor is he's he or she is great
in everything and that includes the
protege which i saw last night in
advance of this interview it's available
in theaters this friday uh starring
maggie q samuel l jackson and this man
michael keaton here on the rich eisen
show how have you been sir good man how
are you i haven't seen you for a while
it's been way too long were you just
talking about rudd paul rudd yeah rudd
is a die-hard chiefs guy but he grew up
loving the steelers and he knew them
like left right up and down by name and
number and everything i knew i liked
this guy
seriously it makes me laugh one day um
we're standing there somewhere at some
event somewhere and i'd never met him
but we kind of nodded each other across
the room
yeah and the person i was with and i
walked over because she had commented
she said paul rudd has the greatest skin
and so i said oh this is perfect
so
so i would notice that hey uh it's nice
to meet you but
more importantly can i say
you have the nicest skin
so did you talk moisturizers with him is
that what you're saying oh that's right
of course obviously that's where it went
how do you moisturize paul
he's very funny
and now man he's a steeler fan that's
really he's yeah i mean he's mr kansas
city and he loves his chiefs but i had
no idea he grew up with the steelers so
uh what do you think of your team going
into this game or should i worry here's
the only here's the only thing i'm
worried about boy maybe i'm gonna get in
trouble for this but boy that wouldn't
be the first time
um dudes 39 right something like that he
is definitely pushing 40. and and but
that's okay because
you when you go
uh you know when you talk about uh
a couple of quarterbacks like the one we
are you know the probably best
you go dude it's like 40 and you go yeah
but i'm sorry man that's forget that
forget that number when it comes to him
with ben i'm not sure he has that
regimen that you know i exactly the two
words you don't usually associate with
ben roethlisberger michael keaton are
health and nuts that's that's you know
what i mean so right so the question is
is what will happen but he does look
more in shape
and here's here's the one guy that i'm
pegging okay for the steelers okay it's
naji harris the kid that they drafted
yeah because this is the way to get ben
to stop in the offense maybe to stop
winging it around 50 times a game
despite how talented their receivers may
be and just give it to this kid and go
back to the old school you know
and that and start hitting people in the
mouth that's the way that'd be great
that's the way i think tomlin i think
deep down that's what he wants to play
it too you know yeah that's changed now
reigning running backs
remember men you you went after running
back that's who you wanted you you you
sought those guys out now
the game so different i think people go
yeah you know running backs i get a
couple years out of one you know you'll
get all beat up and right we'll move on
to the next kit there's always going to
be some really fast kid and some really
good kids in every draft you know that i
mean that's the way it seems to go
because it's such a throwing game now
you know but i don't know you know look
uh
let's let's hope but but they you know
they kind of improved the line a little
bit right yes they did and they and they
get devin bush back in the middle of
that defense
exactly right and i love joe hayden man
uh i think he's he's he's like a unicorn
back there any year 12 for him
i don't know you know and obviously tj
watt they're kind of like the shrug
emoji team they could be
they could be dreadful um based on maybe
getting hurt uh with some important
players or they could just be
the surprise of 2021 and a nice little
throwback for that would be awesome by
the way yes
that's the first are you did you coin
shrug emoji yeah i i don't know did i'll
ask my guys around here uh they're a
shrug emoji too we've been kind of
saying it let's do it right now
yes michael i love that yes either
because because there are some emojis
that will never
happen like
like
let me think this over i'll get right
back to your emotions that's way too
complicated
i would love that that would be that
would be a nice little shorthand
you could put people off for a long time
michael keaton here uh on the rich eisen
show i love this movie brother the
protege yeah it was it's it's you know
directed by the the same director of
casino royale and it does have
a great spy thriller kick ass vibe to it
with maggie q you and
samuel l jackson why why did you say yes
to this one why did you say it let's do
it because that guy really can direct
this stuff uh and and i i thought but
wait have i done
this exactly
and uh
when i saw it i thought oh this is this
is pretty this is fun writing it's it's
kind of clever and and i thought have i
have i done this
and i thought to myself i'm not sure i
really did have done this kind of movie
uh character so i thought well let me
see if i can get away with one more
until they all figure me out
well you are moving around man and
you're doing you're you're you're doing
some uh nifty maneuvers um you know and
in fight scenes and then in terms of the
writing there's a scene with you and
maggie q in a restaurant in a diner you
know you're eating or not eating but
you're having dinner in quotes and uh
you know my wife and i were watching it
we're like that was a hell of a scene
like the back and forth that the two of
you have oh that's cool a woman saw it
unlike this she did encourage my wife
did indeed yes yeah that's good that is
a good scene that gets pointed out quite
a bit uh that's what i mean you know i i
read it and i thought oh this could be
fun you know um i haven't quite played
this guy yeah it's good you know and you
know as far as the other stuff the
physical stuff you know let's face it
you know what what which one of us did
who of us didn't men goofy stupid men
didn't grow up and go wouldn't it be
cool if i could just be
[Laughter]
don't forget the tux yeah just looks so
cool doing it let me see if i can do
that one time
and it's in theaters near you this
friday august 20th um again the protege
great movie maggie q samuel l jackson
and michael keaton here on the rich
eisen show if you would not uh mind
indulging me uh i i we have a game here
called celebrity true or false where
it's kind of a way for us to go through
somebody's filmography and you have a
vast one and police records i think
there is there's a lot of stuff that
people are wondering if it's true or
false that's out there on your
biographies and stuff like that
we even have we even have uh a nice
little fun little drop for that sort of
thing right here michael keaton on the
rich eisen show with celebrity true or
false
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth okay do you like our
production value michael do you like the
production okay here's the first one uh
michael keaton celebrity true or false
you got your acting start playing one of
the flying zucchini brothers on mr
rogers neighborhood mostly true okay
mostly true what's what's the mostly
true part well someone plays at the same
time if you if you want to call being
one of the zooks acting that's okay with
me
now this is a pittsburgh legend though
right mr rogers these guys were wild man
they were so fun
um and you know that happened while we
were we were all crew guys you know
which meant you did a wide variety of
things
so most of them had been on the miss
rogers crew you know you he didn't work
exclusively on that because he had to do
everything so one day uh nikki tala
who's a legendary character here in
pittsburgh
was tatted up and pierced way before
everybody else and
uh he goes uh he does this silly thing
and somebody
bends over picks up a wrench and flips
it to him and goes hey
and then somebody did it so we started
goofing around inventing these
ridiculous
circus tricks and uh
we got like popular and then we came up
with these
um weird costumes a lot of long
underwear
and
and uh
and then we'd get hired like court
jesters like we went to this really rich
woman's party one time
and uh
by the way walked off with a few things
sticky fingers are very fine if you're a
flying zucchini brother they are hey you
know we're we're some just crazy italian
guys who are trying to make a living
so so that was that and that was really
fun those guys were really fun guys to
hang out with next one uh michael keaton
celebrity true or false you originally
turned down beetlejuice and then
ad-libbed 90 of the dialogue in the film
is that true or false 90 might be high
90s high okay but it's well over 50 but
yes that's true so you
why'd you turn it down and then uh and
and then ad lib most of the the film
couldn't understand what tim was trying
to describe
because if you think about it
try
you know let's say you never saw it and
you said this idea you you be the guy
saying okay here's what i'm trying to
make
and and i knew i liked him um you know i
thought he was i just like the guy and i
said oh boy this is this is some
creative person but i don't know what
he's talking about so
i i you know it so no thanks but you
know i enjoyed meeting you and then
somebody said no give it another shot
you know just go talk to him so i did
and i went same thing i like this guy
but i don't quite get what he's talking
about then about the third one i think i
said okay he he threw out some stuff
that was a little more specific and i
went
and by the way he wasn't being coy about
it he was really trying hard
and i wasn't getting it and then he gave
me some he said you know i don't know
maybe this isn't i go all right
give me the night to think this over i
got a couple ideas so then i went
home
i had the
studio send me over a rack of
clothing i said just just go into the
lot grab me this this this this this
this this and then i was alone in my
house acting can you imagine that how's
that picture by the way me walking
around like that by myself at my house
how bad is that
then i thought you know what you know
what's weird and kind of weirdly scary
teeth that aren't too big but just big
enough to be really off-putting to
someone
so i so i said make me some like teeth
and then i had this idea for
mold on my face and i just said all
right
i said how about this what do you think
and he goes well okay we we never
rehearsed it we never rehearsed it
we just he i just showed up started
doing that i thought this is either
going to work or not work
um and tim was awesome
it worked so which is your favorite
ad-lib line one that you're most proud
of if you can um pick one up well
i mean
that whole that riff i kind of like when
i i don't um
when i do that i'm kind of selling
something i dress up in some kind of
really bad faux cowboy wear and there's
a cow a big plastic cop thing and i kind
of made this goofy little song up um
because there was a guy in and man
there's so many i can't rem i can't
remember i do this really ridiculous
dance that i love but but then but the
thing i'm referring to there was a guy
in l.a when i moved out there
named cal worthington i don't know if i
remember this guy
he had a late night it was always on
late at night and he sold the cars
and his thing was i'll eat a bug i'm
count-worthy and i'll eat a bug and he
would eat a bug if i forget what the
deal was
and i'd wear a cowboy hat every once in
a while and i thought oh i want to do
something like that
i don't know what that is but you know
so but there were so many you know and
then tim was great because if you did
something he went oh yes do that and
then walk over here and and do that like
when i
when i walk over and
do the
kick the trigger and go you know i think
it was there was some joke it might have
been nice model but then i threw in the
f word
and grabbed my crotch i thought you know
what somebody told me i don't know if
it's true or not somebody told me the
sensor you know they used to send
somebody into a screening room
and then
pick things and go nope can't do that
nope can't say that no someone told me
she fell asleep during that period and
missed it
i don't know if that's true or not but
so we got away with saying that
oh man i've got two more for you here
michael keaton celebrity true or false
true or false you negotiated a break in
your batman contract in case the pirates
made the playoffs is that true that's
true that was kind of an ongoing thing
for several movies but by the way
they all
and that's when they were good but
imagine them doing now they go fine
don't worry about that
no problem that's the first yes they get
from legal so but this is back when
obviously we're talking about the bonds
vents like
pirates right that's what we're talking
about they were in it they were always
in there oh man the gym leland smoking
heaters in between innings
you know okay and then the last one for
you true or false you and martin mull
improvise the 220 221 whatever it takes
exchange in mr mom that troll totally
martin's
he goes uh
what i mean we did i ended up saying is
that he goes uh um we're watching what
they can improvise
like moments before not improvised i
said the prop guy said you know i need
something this scene uh
you know this guy's really insecure
right now he's panicked you know i think
something then and i go yeah you don't
have any tools and uh
you know getting like and i was looking
for some tools and and then either he
mentioned a chainsaw or i did
and that he was so great he like ran to
the problem scrambling around came out
and i said yeah yeah yeah perfect and
then he handed me the goggles he said
you want these they go absolutely give
me those so
so then we started shooting the scene
and
doing that and um that line you know the
setup is uh so i'm telling him i'm
working on a house and i don't know what
i'm doing and he says so you can wired
you know 220 and then and then i i kind
of i think i really like it was i kind
of fake i go uh yeah or something like
that
and he thinks he says you know what you
should say say 220 221 you know i think
he's either i said whatever it takes he
did but yeah
he came up with that well i mean he's as
uh he's as legendary as they come man i
mean martin mull for the
fernwood tonight i mean and you you've
been just
this has been an amazing uh conversation
michael and um
i i
i barely just scratching the surface on
everything spotlight birdman are just
incredible films
that you are in the trial of the chicago
seven i mean obviously
um what we just talked about as well the
protege you also have worth coming on
netflix in september and then dope sick
which is yeah i'm already making
appointment viewing for that on hulu on
october 13th i've seen some honestly i
it's it's it's awfully good it's it's
really really good and man it's it's uh
it's gonna it's gonna be eye-opening i
think uh for a lot of people before i
leave you know what i keep asking people
to mention and sometimes they remember
sometimes they don't
um and i know this is a
male centric show probably but
people don't
talk about how great terry gar was you
know and
mr mom is mr mom but in all that stuff
young frankenstein people forget man she
was she was it
you know she was she was
funny and smart and witty and
quirky and charming and great looking
and that there were very few people that
mention her now like when they mention
the really
funny women so i i always try to mention
her no question we were talking about
again prior to the show like which one
of your films from your way back in the
day filmography we could ask you about
and i mentioned how terrific terry guard
was beforehand
no no no question about it wasn't she
she was also i think in the conversation
too which is a great brilliant movie
that people don't talk about and also
uh
that
plays the mom doesn't she play the mom
in black beauty uh that that uh
really awesome uh with mickey i'm not
kidding this gorgeous movie about this
kid in this horse it's stunningly
beautiful yeah
young
and
as you pointed out too oh my gosh
i don't know if you're aware too but
tomorrow is the 38th anniversary of the
premiere of mr mom michael get out
really it's a fact
wow the day before the protege there you
go look at you that's a tiny that's a
classic a little classic all right i'm
going to leave you alone
michael keaton no no
good dog man i know that you and i share
that
love of animals and dogs
my wife and i we have two beautiful
rescues at home and uh life is good
certainly when we get a chance to
connect um i'd love to do this again
whenever you are michael keaton this
place is open to you and enjoy the
steelers season we'll chat down the line
okay man you got it that's michael
keaton everybody at michael keaton on
twitter at michael keaton douglas
on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here